talk to us Evan please a little bit
about about the book your one word how
did that idea come to fruition like was
it something you've been planning all
along or were you just wondering like
I'm going to write a book let's make
this happen I never want to write a book
of my things my agent Steve in New York
is like we need a book read above I need
a book to sell you went to corporations
and all this stuff ugh I don't want a
book speed look at my youtube channel I
can open up doors and is not this night
it's not 1950 anymore right like you
don't need as well to open up doors yes
sir I mean he's like okay I'm going to
beat you anyway into publishers okay
whatever pitch me is no matter and then
through that process I was figuring out
my one word believe I started branding
my business around believe my website
was about believe my newsletters about
believe i was making videos about
believe everything that was believed
related took off way more than anything
else and so and it's one because it's
easy to understand and market but two is
like it was more mean-spirited its
believers not just a marketing thing
it's authentic for me it's what I am and
so it's curious to then find other
businesses but I'm going to do this
crazy thing and build my entire business
around one word it sounds nuts and I
started finding other businesses that
had done it and from the guy we just
build a fifty-thousand-dollar full time
income from shells around one word to
then a business at half a million
dollars a billion dollars five million
dollars at 150 million dollars in
revenue and when I was interview these
people and they all just figured it out
nobody had a blueprint there was no
plans budget be pretty cool if there was
a plan like if there's a book that i
want to write that's the book i want to
right ghosts or not there's other stuff
that you guys are pitching me and so i
was really reluctant at the start I'd
like didn't want to do it at all I was
just following my agents and like didn't
want to take calls do you want to do
like we think a call that give us the
proposal
I don't want to do both all you want to
do what but then when this idea here
like sky this is it this is the thing
and they thought they hated it at the
start they're like that's a workbook
things like so less like five pages of a
worksheet like are you kidding me this
is amiss is more than a book this is a
series for a book they want like 60,000
words that's how much like a typical
book is maybe I wrote a hundred and
twenty thousand words we cut half the
book we cut an entire book oh because
you said vol.2 no no no like that when i
thinkI keeping I'm throwing that way
like I remember nothing but something
different like just grind out the work
and I'll throw away more than what most
people will even create and still like
that's the best of the 120 thousand
words condensed down to 60 or 65 or
whatever it is I just got really excited
about being able to teach the concept
and I thought it would actually lend
itself better to a book because of the
activities and exercises then making
YouTube videos thank you guys so much
for watching thank you to the guide some
v and our media for the awesome
interview the full link is in the
description below if you want to check
it out I love to know what did you think
what are your thoughts leave them in the
comments below I'm super curious to find
out finally I want to give a quick shout
at the den call i hope i pronounced that
okay then thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word i
really really really really appreciate
it and i hope you're enjoying the reach
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon